des vitraux digne d'une cathédrale un
éclairage recréant la voûte céleste un
soir de septembre
pourtant le maître de chai son équipe
n'ont pas le temps de rêvasser
après les vendanges aujourd'hui c'est
l'heure du décuvage et du pressage
pour le vigneron 7 cuverie est bien plus
qu'un bel endroit c'est surtout un lieu
qui nous permet aussi de faire du
meilleur narrer c'est à dire que c'est
une enchère qu'on appelle gravitaire
c'est à dire que nous réceptionnons les
raisins à un niveau et ensuite nous
mettons tout en tonneau par gravité donc
l'idée c'est de ne pas utiliser de
pompes et de ne pas abîmer les jus
commencer au printemps 2014 la
construction de cette cuve riz devait
s'achever fin 2015 finalement les
travaux dureront quatre ans 1500 mètres
carrés plus de 2000 mètres cubes de
béton 160 pu planter à 20 mètres de
profondeur un projet pharaonique conduit
par frédéric didier architecte en chef
aux monuments historiques
il a tenu à conserver le patrimoine de
cet ancien couvent le défi a été
d'essayer d'implanter ce bâtiment grand
en sauvant les cavs qui était en dessous
une de mes fiertés a été non seulement
de pouvoir réaliser ce bâtiment comme je
l'entendais mais également de pouvoir
faire appel à des amis artistes
sculpteur à maître verrier est un
artiste paysager qui a conçu le toit du
dôme
en fait cette colline habiter avec une
idée qui est à la fois de prolonger la
vigne et en même temps une une citation
subliminal sur les toits de bourgogne
impossible de connaître le coût de cette
construction
et si la famille boisset s'en défend au
delà de l'outil de vinification ce lieu
d'exception va devenir un formidable
ambassadeur de la marque familiale on
serait pas forcément se démarquer on
souhaite exprimer notre personnalité
le lieu a été créé pour les vins c'est à
dire pas pour l' architecture mais pour
magnifier les vins et leur donner un
cocon qui est celui qui nous nous
imaginions le plus adapté à leur
épanouissement
cette cuverie hors norme va devenir un
non pas douter un site incontournable de
la côte viticole
elle devrait être ouverte aux visiteurs
dès la fin de l'année